Cô chừng góan không dân dù ăn đổ mối lý thà mò hơn ngày 3 xong cho biết,
cụm điều tra tay nạn hàng không đang tiếng hành của điều tra toàn dịt,
bụ tay nạn nhìn trọng xảy ra ngày 2 xong, tại bàn của trở rát.
Chứ buốing bày tả bẩy tảm, Dreamliner của hàng A,
in jail, rồi chỉ vài phút sau khi cất cảnh đâm xuống gí túc xa
chừng cầu đảng ý khoa bây chai khiến gần 3 chăm người.
khiến cơ quan điều tra đằng xem mọi khả năng,
trong đó có yếu tố 3 hỏi.
Các biệt ra, mình tại khu dực xin bây và các sự hiệu liên quan đang được phân tích
với sự poe hợp từ nhiều cơ quan truyền môn.
Ông mô nhấn mạnh ảnh đổ sẽ tự tiến hành toàn bộ quá trình điều tra không gửi hộp đen xả nước ngoài.
Háng hình không ở anh, chưa khảnh đình mấy bây đất bảo chì đầy đủ và tổ lại có kinh nghiệp.
Chúng khi đó, một số chuyên xa hành không có tế kêu gọi minh bạc thông tin
đồng thời để nghĩ tiếp tận hiện chương để hỗ trợ điều tra.
Đây là một trong những thảm ỏ hành không nghiêm trọng nhất tại hành động trong nhiều năng quá.
Và có thể để lại hộ quả lương xanh, đối với ngày hành không dân dụng nước này.